Hablemos sobre variación directa e inversa.
Entonces del lado izquierdo,
voy a poner variación directa... la directa,
y en el lado derecho pongo la inversa.
Entonces variación directa e inversa,
una definición sencilla para dos variables que,
que varían directamente,
sería algo así como,
"y" varía directamente con "x" ,
si "y" es igual a una constante multiplicada por "x",
ajá,
lo podemos escribir en nuestro lenguaje como...
como "y" varía directamente con "x".
Así que "y" varía directamente con "x",
y si esta constante "k" te parece algo extraña,
solo recuerda que puede ser cualquier número,
literalmente cualquier número, el que se te ocurra.
Entonces te daré algunos ejemplos particulares,
donde "y" varía directamente con "x",
podríamos decir que
"y" es igual a "x"
aquí ni siquiera puse el 1 es igual "k",
ni siquiera lo puse, pero lo podemos poner,
ajá,
otro ejemplo sería "y" igual a 2 por "x",
o "y" igual a un medio por "x",
o "y"... "y" igual a "-2x",
también eso es variar directamente,
"y"...
"y" igual a menos un medio por "x",
incluso
"y" igual a pi por "x", ajá,
pi por "x",
o también "y" igual a menos pi por "x",
creo que aquí ya tiene sentido
o creo que ya entiendes
lo que lo que es variar directamente.
Y para entenderlo un poco mejor,
voy a elegir algún ejemplo concreto de estos que puse
y voy a tomar la versión positiva y la versión negativa.
Entonces tomemos por ejemplo,
a "y" igual a "2x",
tenemos "y" igual a "2x"
y veamos porque se dice que varían directamente.
Voy a elegir algunos valores para "x"
y veamos que resulta,
de "y" al poner ese valor de "x" en la ecuación.
Entonces si yo tengo por ejemplo "y" igual a 1
"y" es igual a 2 por 1, eso es igual a 2,
si yo tengo "x" es igual a 2, entonces,
"y" es igual a 2 por 2, eso es 4,
y podemos ver que al duplicar "x"
lo que sucede es que también duplicamos a "y" ,cierto,
entonces duplicó a "x"
y se duplica el valor de "y".
Y justo a eso nos referimos
cuando algo varía directamente ,
aquí yo duplique a "x" y "y",
también se duplicó, entonces si crece "x"
también crece "y" en la misma proporción.
Si yo elijo valores negativos para "x"
también va a decrecer en la misma...
en la misma escala,
que "x"
"y" también va a decrecer.
Entonces veamos qué pasa si yo
elijo a "y" igual a "-2x"
"-2x" no,
mejor a "-3x",
entonces pongo aquí la "x" y la "y",
y ok...
si "x" es igual a 1
"y" es igual a -3,
ajá, si "x" es igual a 2,
"y" es igual a -6,
-3 por 2 es igual a -6
nota que aumentamos a "x" por 2, cierto,
ajá,
lo pongo en el mismo color verde que...
que lo puse allá... bueno no es el mismo exactamente,
pero sirve...
Entonces aumente a "x" por 2
y lo mismo pasó con "y"
se duplicó,
así que para llegar de 1 a 2 multiplicamos por 2,
para llegar de -3 a -6,
multiplicamos por 2.
Aumentó proporcionalmente
y si queremos ir en la otra dirección,
digamos, vamos a intentarlo con...
qué te parece "x" igual a un tercio,
si "x" es igual a un tercio,
entonces "y" es igual a -3 por un tercio,
eso igual a -1,
ajá, nota que de 1 a un tercio,
lo que hicimos fue dividir entre...
entre 3,
y para llegar de -3 a -1,
también dividimos entre 3, cierto,
entonces hicimos lo mismo,
sea cual sea la dirección
que tienes para "x"
en esa misma dirección va a variar "y",
a eso es lo que...
eso es a lo que nos referimos
cuando hablamos sobre variación directa,
ahora
no siempre es tan claro porque, ok,
el asunto no siempre es tan claro...
veamos voy a tomar este ejemplo,
este ejemplo "y" igual a  "-3x"
y lo podemos manipular algebraicamente,
quizás dividir entre
ambos lados entre "x".
Entonces voy a hacer eso,
tendríamos...
tendríamos "y" sobre "x", es igual,
a -3
o también podríamos hacer,
lo que acabamos de hacer,
dividir ambos lados entre "x"
y después dividir ambos lados entre "y"
entonces obtendríamos...
obtendríamos...
1 sobre "x" es igual,
a -3 multiplicado por 1 sobre "y".
Todas estas ecuaciones,
dicen exactamente lo mismo, puedes ver que...
que la variación directa no es siempre tan...
tan directa o bueno, siempre directa,
pero no es tan clara obvia...
no es tan obvia sería la palabra.
Ahora puedes manipular esto
a la forma original también,
y hay otras maneras,
de hecho,
podríamos hacer esto,
dividir ambos lados entre..
entre -3
y obtendríamos menos un tercio "y" igual a "x"
y esto es interesante porque aquí,
esto es el equivalente a "x" varía
directamente con "y",
ajá, o "x" es igual a...
alguna constante "k",
por "x", en general es verdad,
si "y" varía directamente con "x",
"x" varía directamente con "y".
Ahora, no va a ser la misma constante, claro,
pero si será el inverso de esa constante
y, ok, aunque así están variando directamente,
no, no importa mucho...
Ahora vamos con variación inversa,
ok, ya vimos bastante de variación directa,
aquí podría ir cualquier variable, cierto,
"a" y "b", "m" y "n" y entonces sería por ejemplo,
con "m" y "n",
"m" varía directamente con "n"
o "m" es igual a "k",
alguna constante "k" por "n"
pero ahora trabajemos con variación inversa,
entonces tenemos...
tendríamos alguna "y" igual a alguna constante "k" por...
multiplicada por 1 sobre "x",
entonces en lugar de ser "k" por "x",
ahora tenemos "k" por 1 sobre "x" .
Algunos ejemplos serían "y"
igual a 1 sobre "x",
o "y" igual a 2 por 1 sobre "x",
lo cual es claramente 2 sobre "x"
También por ejemplo, "y" igual a un tercio por 1 sobre "x", lo cual es igual,
a 1 sobre "3x"
o también "y" igual a -2 sobre "x",
y vamos a explorar la variación inversa,
de la misma manera que
exploramos la variación directa,
así que voy a elegir,
digamos a "y" iguala a 2 sobre "x"...
entonces "y" igual a 2 sobre "x"...
y pongo la misma tabla...
tenemos los valores de "x" aquí,
y los valores de "y"
ok, si "x" es igual a 1, "y" es igual a 2,
si "x" es igual a 2, "y" es igual a 1,
entonces si yo estoy multiplicando a "x" por 2,
si lo incremento por un factor de 2
¿qué sucede con "y"?
"y"va a decrementar en un valor de 2 también,
entonces,
nota que...
nota la diferencia, aquí si yo aumento a "x",
aumenta "y" en la misma escala, ajá,
y acá si yo aumento a "x",
entonces el valor de "y",
va a decrecer en la misma escala que "x",
y en la otra dirección, si por ejemplo,
"x" es igual a un medio,
estamos bajando en "x",
estamos yendo de 1 a un medio,
vemos que... que "y" va a aumentar,
porque 2 dividido entre 1... entre un medio,
es igual a 4,
ajá, puedes ver que "y" aumenta,
y en general, lo que está aquí pasando,
es que están haciendo lo opuesto, cierto,
están variando inversamente,
de ahí está el nombre, variando inversamente,
y claro, no siempre tiene esta forma bonita
y entendible pero...
pero se puede acomodar de muchas maneras,
y no dejará de ser por eso, variación inversa,
por ejemplo, podría... podría ser que
manipulándolo algebraicamente siempre,
siempre que sean equivalentes algebraicamente,
esto a estas otras opciones,
como por ejemplo "x" por "y" igual a dos,
estoy simplemente
multiplicando por "X",
tendremos la misma tabla,
o a esto dividirlo entre "y",
tendríamos "x" es igual a 2 sobre "y"
2 sobre "y",
o lo que es lo mismo, igual a 2 por 1 sobre "y",
así que nota esto,
"y" varía  inversamente con "x",
y puedes manipular esto algebraicamente,
para mostrar que "x" varía inversamente con "y",
ajá, entonces...
entonces "y" varía inversamente con "x"
esto...
esto es exactamente lo mismo
que "x" varía inversamente con "y"...
"x" varia inversamente con "y",
y hay más...
hay más...
podríamos tomar esto
y dividir ambos lados entre 2,
obtendríamos que,
"y" sobre 2 es igual a 1 sobre "x",
hay muchas cosas locas aquí,
en general si tú...
si, si tú ves una expresión,
que se relacione con variables, ya sea que
varía inversamente o directamente o ninguna,
entonces puedes hacer una tabla de este estilo
y para valores de "x" y "y"
aumenta entonces hablas de variación directa
y si pones valores para "x"
donde "x" se incrementa,
pero "y" está decreciendo,
entonces eso es variación inversa,
ahora lo más sencillo es,
manipular estas ecuaciones algebraicamente,
para ver a qué forma llegas,
si llegas a esta forma
estarás hablando de variación inversa
y si llegas a esta forma,
entonces hablas de variación directa.